there are a lot of pivotal movie scenes
that really require thespians to crank
up the waterworks and send home the
emotion of the moment so how do these
stars manage to trickle out those tears
again and again with each take let's
take a look at how some of Hollywood's
finest well.get happen it may not be
common but there are some actors who
have the ability to summon up authentic
sobs by sheer force of well and loss of
practice Bryce Dallas Howard famously
demonstrated her natural gift for crying
on command during an interview with
Conan O'Brien shedding tears while
listening to the talk show host till a
nonsensical story about the variety of
duct tape at Home Depot
duct tape while kinds of duct tape you
can get great duct tape yeah can you do
this incredible thing you give so much
and you get so little in return
the actress late to return for the same
show and reveal that a teary talent is
far from genetic it's something that can
be learned and taught and you just need
to give me a little bit of money right
according to Howard inducing the soft
palate lift that comes with yawning
again and again it's key in helping her
produce those crocodile tears
the actress revealed you do it enough
time and when you're talking you can
continue to lift her it triggers it just
talking about it for me it's like a
physiological thing how would also added
that the biggest key to crying on cue is
making sure to stay completely hydrated
- there's plenty of h2o to spare in her
system amy adams can also turn on the
sprinklers at a moment's notice
but instead of relying on a physical
trick the actress claims that she uses
quite a spicy memory to make the
waterworks happen Adams told Jimmy
Fallon that a daughter helped coax her
into crying on cue by telling her about
a sriracha plant in California that was
shuttered after neighboring residents
complained about the fumes coming from
the production facility I really liked
her ah-choo and I don't know if you
heard but they were thinking of closing
the plant okay maybe it was a put-on but
just try named a bigger sriracha fan we
dare you Anna Faris revealed to
late-night host James Corden but she
isn't the type of person who can easily
sub in real life meaning it's that much
more difficult for her to cry on camera
the actress said is actually a little
bit weird if I ever cried in my personal
life my mom would sort of come down on
me like what do you have to feel sorry
for so in
sort of trying to power through with
real tears Faris relies on a device
called a TS tech Faris Corden and fellow
guest Josh Jackson each agreed to have
the menthol crystal vapors blown into
their eyes to demonstrate for the crowd
and within seconds they were dripping
with tears
that's when Jackson revealed the
secondary trick to selling these fake
tears on screen look three-quarters away
and slightly up yeah Naoto some actors
turn tough to stretch their minds too
far to work up the requisite tears for a
tough scene Daniel Kahlua revealed that
while filming a standout song complete
scene for Jordan peels gets out in which
his character was physically frozen in
fear he simply thought about what it
would be like to be in a similar
situation in real life in an actor's on
actors chart for variety
kahlúa explained that a large part of
tapping into that headspace to cry
involved recognizing the parallels
between his character's situation and
everyday scenarios saying it's just
empathizing with someone that's going
through so much in a suppressed a kind
of suppressed his guilt of a really bad
situation in shame and also his
reluctance to face it he's paralyzed
he's paralyzed emotionally and I
identified with that in all walks of
life
Anderson unforgettable cinematic crying
scene was born
[Music]
now you're in a sunken place empathy is
a valuable trait and certainly helpful
in crying on cue but if an actor has his
or her own harrowing life experience to
help bring the sad sobs to the set it's
even better for one of his first films
after his Harry Potter days Daniel
Radcliffe started to beat poet Allen
Ginsberg and the biographical drama
thriller kill your darlings the role
required Radcliffe to shed a lot of
Tears something that wasn't exactly easy
for the actor to do radda cliff told The
Vancouver Sun unless you have that trick
of being able to cry on cue which some
people can do the more you try to force
it the more awkward and awful it becomes
as I have found
unfortunately there's no magic spell to
summon tears however Radcliffe revealed
that he revisited a helpful pointer from
Gary Oldman to help him turn on the
waterworks the actor said his former
on-screen Godfather once told him don't
be afraid to use all your own stuff
because they're only going to see it
happening to the character but would you
weren't gonna tell me we both know why
you can't come
Radcliffe didn't share what memory did
the trick exactly but revealed that he
did find some success with it saying
three uncontrollable breaking down
scenes later there were these real
brought tears the first time that
happens to you on a set full of people
even if you go in just as a character at
that moment it is just you know that's
some magical moment if we've ever heard
one without a built-in trick or
handy-dandy device to help bring on the
waterworks some actors just have to jump
into an emotional scene feet first and
hope their eyes catch up somewhere along
the way Oscar winner Jennifer Lawrence
revealed that for one of her big crime
scenes she actually went through the
bodily motions of mourning and the tears
happened to follow suit the actress told
MTV news
I can definitely start sobbing and water
comes sometimes I don't have anything in
my life that can instantly make me cry
it's mostly just a standard hold your
eyes open fake your way through it
Lawrence later elaborated that she needs
to widen her eyes for a long time to
make a method work but that it's still
her go-to for the gushy scenes
considering how stacked her trophy shelf
is right about now whatever she's doing
is obviously working just fine
Will Smith might have no trouble serving
up serious drama now that he's such a
seasoned film star but back in his
earliest days on The Fresh Prince of
bel-air Smith was still learning how to
a mote on camera his starring sitcom
role almost always relied on his skill
for being suave and self-assured but
there was one important moment in the
show's fourth season that required the
actor to really dig deep in the poignant
episode Will's father returns to his
life and gives a teen hope and he might
finally forge a bond with a man who's
been m.i.a
throughout his upbringing however he
doesn't stick around for long and will
delivers a heartbreaking monologue that
facilitates between contempt
determination and a lot of hurts
without the strong delivery by Smith the
scene might have been hokey but he sold
his sadness thanks to the help of his
on-screen uncle James Avery Smith
revealed James Avery was relentlessly on
me to elevate he was like you have this
position look where you are look what
you were blessed with he was like I'm
sorry but I'm not accepting anything
other than absolute committed perfection
from you Hollywood history is filled
with stories of filmmakers using near
torturous techniques to elicit an
emotional response from their stars like
when Alfred Hitchcock tormented Tippi
Hedren on the set of the birds to
capture real fear or when Stanley
Kubrick made Shelley Duvall unwell with
his harsh demands on the set of The
Shining and her condition conveniently
aligned with the characters similarly
there have been several noteworthy cases
of cast members being coerced into
crying on set by some of their
co-workers whether they liked it or not
for example when he was still a child
star Jackie Cooper was bullied by
director norman taurog into bringing it
with his tears and skip a foe the role
earned that their nine-year-old an Oscar
nomination it's safe to say that taurog
threat to kill Cooper's dog if the actor
didn't cry took things a bit too far
similarly Francis Ford Coppola
reportedly resorted to calling Winona
Ryder vicious names to bring her to
tears on the set of Bram Stoker's
Dracula there are some actors so
talented that they simply don't have a
need to turn to methods or manufacturing
when they're called to be emotionally
affected in a scene in a surprise to no
one Meryl Streep largely considered the
greatest actress of our time is one of
those skilled few in a discussion with
the students of the University of Texas
Streep revealed that our process is
simply to power through whatever
challenge she faces including bringing
tears to the table even when she isn't
actually in the mopey mood the actress
said the hardest thing to do is to do
something when you don't feel it it's
weird and hard to do what isn't really
happening and make it like it is but we
need actors we need them to help us
understand different emotions and
realities to console us to let us know
that we're not alone in other words
whenever Streep needs to cry on screen
she simply remembers how important that
is for Meryl Streep to cry on screen and
she gets her job done that kind of
gumption just can't be taught so it's no
she's so many light years ahead of the
rest oprah winfrey seems to be good at
everything but when the TV mogul does
occasionally dip her toes into the
waters of Hollywood to star in a movie
it's not always easy for her in fact to
win if we told Ari King that before she
earned an Academy Award nomination for
her work in the color purple she felt
like a failure because she could only
cry when the cameras were pointed
elsewhere drawing production as soon as
they were facing her the tears were
nowhere to be found
so all night long I cried because it
couldn't cry when if we later revealed
that before she began working on Lee
Daniels the butler she decided to bring
in some help and learn how to fake some
of that raw emotion I came so easily on
her daytime talk show Winfrey said
everybody thinks I'm a good crier an
easy crier I can cry if I'm in the
moment and feeling emotion but as an
actress that was one of my biggest fears
thanks for the enlistment of an acting
coach Winfrey said she figured out how
to make herself cry in just 20 minutes
now that's something that jump up and
down about the late great Shirley Temple
might have been just a tiny tyke when
she became a legend of the early screen
scene but even then she was a consummate
professional in a 1999 interview the
former child superstar revealed her
method for breaking out with a whale on
camera saying I guess there was an early
method actress I would go to a quiet
part of the soundstage with my mother I
wouldn't think of anything sad I would
just make my mind a blank in a minute I
could cry temple did have one crying
caveat though the Hollywood legend said
she didn't like to cry out to lunch
because she was too content who can be
sad after chowing down on animal
crackers in their soup check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movie stars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]